bon Serge Gainsbourg là on entre dans la
grande politique les guerres les grèves
les problèmes sociaux en France vous
allez prendre la voix de la succession
d'Yves Montand pendant 2 minutes
auparavant vous avez vu ce qui arrive
aux États-Unis un homme mal rasé
vous avez vu ça ça vous a fait peur
d'ailleurs
vous n'aimez pas la violence en tout cas
j'aime la violence verbale je n'aime pas
la violence physique
si vous avez ici vos mesurer de mètres
40 peser 90 kg peut-être que vous
aimeriez la vie en physique aussi nous
que je vais contre une veste
j'ai jamais pris une garde du corps j'ai
un garde du corps ça fait jamais que
demain
et sur les manifs les grèves ça va se
auparavant une question sur Noah Noah
vous connaissez le débat autour de Noah
vous pensez que sa fille ne saute pas la
veille des matchs des marchés
de la façon dont ça se passe bon alors
le les problèmes économiques les
problèmes sociaux comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on dit ça quand on est
un des artistes les mieux payés de
France
on pense que ça va ça
va être le merdier je vais vous donner
un petit compte parabolique en 1981 mais
en mai 81 j'ai trouvé
une super nana
[Musique]
je m'appelle socialiste
après on monte
et se débloque
j'étais un immense
elle se tourne
président
[Musique]
c'était une parabole maintenant ceci dit
on va tellement dans le foutoir je vais
bientôt c'est pas du café qu'on va voir
c'est de l'eau chaude
et maintenant je vais vous dire ce que a
changé depuis 3 ans non et puis rien
mais le raquette des impôts je veux dire
ce que je veux faire ça c'est pas une
parabole c'est du fils
je prends un billet de 500 balles
je vais vous dire je suis taxé à
74%
je vais vous dire ce qui me reste
c'est bien c'est illégal ce que je vais
faire
ici
voilà je vais vous dire ce qu'il me
reste
j'arrêterai à 74%
[Musique]
. il faut quand même pas déconner parce
que ça c'est pas pour les pauvres c'est
pour le nucléaire et toutes que vous
provoquez beaucoup de monde en faisant
ça écoutez c'est bon
quartier latin voyage quand vous le
voulez et puis plus maintenant non non
c'est foutu
qu'est-ce qui est foutu vous pouvez plus
travailler comme autrefois j'aimerais
que les pauvres et tous des roses
et moi j'ai vendu à miel voilà le
travail socialiste le drame de Serge
Gainsbourg c'est qu'il a vendu français
[Musique]